carrie mulligan have you recovered from
what sounds like
a very traumatic christmas we all had a
slightly odd christmas
but yours very bad oh mine was well yeah
so i was i was
coming into london and laden with a huge
suitcase of i was going to go and sort
of socially distance drop things off
um presents and things to my nieces and
i was at the train station
and i had my headphones in and i was
listening to taylor swift
having like the nicest time on my own
for a moment without my kids my coffee
had a latte and then i sort of
went to sanitize my hands because i
touched the left door
and so i got my sanitizer out put my
coffee down and
my my suitcase just wheeled off the
platform
with my coffee and one of my headphones
no no but here's the weird thing so
that's traumatic enough
did you take this picture
so that's your coffee as well that's my
coffee i know and actually my airpod as
well which was so annoying
um but then there were like seven men
who went down to go and collect it
and and it was on the tip of my tongue
to say could you please see if my
airport is not worth it
[Music]
you